hello everybody my name is Mark Lyon I'm
here once again with Wade hi Wade how
you do hey it was a scary night it was
it was a really scary night here are
some of the noises we heard last night
yeah not that it wasn't one oh wait you
don't need to reconnect it I have a gray
we have footage I've been recording this
whole time
I even got those dirty things you said
like this yeah no wait God is not good I
was gonna cut your words together to
make something horrible okay anybody
anyway but our plan for this round is
I'm gonna try to increase my view
distance because I can't see [ __ ]
but what we're gonna do is we're gonna
go north to the forest because it's way
too hot here in the desert um and we're
overheating which means that we're
consuming more water did you know you
get iron from hitting a rock no but I
guess the thought to support a lot of
games have that kind of feature oh you
get iron from hitting rock okay but
either way we need to sprint Northwest
wait are you with me I'm a little bit
ahead probably you stop sheet rock I
kept going oh okay sorry
ours is enamored by the rock and I'm
imagining that the reason you were
feeling so wet is because the cooling
vapors of the forest felt so good on
your skin yes they must feel there why
am i smelling what does my nose mean hey
mouth still good idea maybe you got
allergies and you just can't become some
horrible survivor you are you kid you
have allergy mm-hmm okay that's not you
there you are that was a zombie I was
gonna follow oh don't do that don't do
that at all okay I need um it's only
getting hotter over here that's weird
well it is becoming further into the day
I don't know maybe it's just hot on this
man it is that's a Zombo ooh yep good
thing I followed you right to it
yep you're welcome buddy I'm here to
help you hey why are you beating the
rock lady where she being the oh no time
to build a beast to stop her she's crazy
I could she's a decayed mother oh no she
was just trying to get rock for her
babies everbilly what her name was
yes oh my god how did any
I know it's a decayed mother that
doesn't make any sense so so oh now
she's no longer that she turned ah
[ __ ] criminy god this thing snuck up
on me
Church departed woman oh she had a
pistol oh she had a pistol night what
kind of ammo does it takes I've got
bullets 9-millimeter I might have some
that live look alright where are you I'm
in the middle of all the rocks
all right let me reload this all came
with 15 bullets in the chamber and two
extra bullets I've got three for you
nice I'll take him
all right whenever you come back I'll
give them to you we're late okay so I've
got a buttload of wood frames coming
I've got 30 right now but then one more
on the way there right here in front of
me but you can't see them Wow oh wait I
got him okay I got him
wow that was tiny yeah okay 90 degrees I
think we can work with this it is
getting cooler okay so these wood frames
how do we want to build this house uh I
don't know just we can start off with
something small like one room and then
just expand it as we get time okay then
make a door I'll just start putting down
framework
okay I'm crafting ten wood frames that
I'll make a door okay I'm getting I'm
just getting [ __ ] hurry up well we
can still run back to the other house if
we need to for one more night
I think we'll be okay what does oh god
that was a chainsaw I'm telling you
today daily oh that's really close I I
can get that I can get that it's right
nearby I'll be back baby Wow
why did it get brighter I don't know but
I was able to build in that little hole
you dug so good job there's like okay
there's three I think I can handle three
uh do you have bows and arrows
oh no they stunned me don't do that
don't are you trapped in the house no
don't wait a lot of the house don't die
I mean our rules are literally right in
sight I hate you
don't die wait wait don't do it please
we need you I came out here right is it
this one is so chunky ah no wait no the
big one is so hard to kill away No
I'm gonna make arrows and come back did
you do you just spawned at the thing
right oh [ __ ] I don't have enough
feathers Ivy I haven't been looking for
nests what use the bow and arrow
you hit are to reload it to start it and
then you right-click to look in I don't
have any arrows cuz they were on my body
that died
oh no Sarah take all option
uh I don't know but watch out for this
guy
I'm shooting him oh he's tough where
these guys come from
huh they just wandered up okay he's dead
okay he's got an old sham sandwich that
we don't need we need storage also there
were two more um I killed a nurse yeah
and that guy okay there was one more I'm
not sure where she went then I don't
hear her so I'm assuming everything's
okay yes she must a lot I let my guard
down there everything's alright was it
our tape all yes it is okay oh it's
getting late we don't have proper
defenses do we have a door yeah okay
good I'm so scared
yeah I want to build a campfire in the
middle of our house what does it matter
if your skill in construction is up
maybe you build faster maybe it takes
less resources I don't know it could be
oh I seem to be chopping the wood down a
little faster I guess up know what I
know I'm just now level 2 yeah yeah
you'd eat it
I'm probably dying of hunger by oh
that's the sound of not having any wood
that weird thing was real weird
oh okay do you hear that whatever you
try to build in a wood like it makes
wierd Iggy noise no no maybe just me
then
I think it is okay craft what happened
to my stone
I had stone what the [ __ ] happened to my
stone I had lots of stone so late Oh God
we're so dead it's fine I just need
stone but uh yeah I'm at 25% hunger
jeezum 'z I got a full PI I can give you
do you need it more no I don't think so
ok
coming in oh that's right I spent all my
stone on uh
there you go there's a full pie on the
ground right there it's real small in
front of me but thank you baby
ok hang on don't forget that whoa meat
stew yep don't [ __ ] my inventories full
let me put this campfire down and in the
corner here boink boink ok and then meat
pie eat that pie eat it up hmm it's a
meat student but I'm ok whoo I think
we'll be fine if there's no roof right I
think so I'm gonna build up one more
layer ok oh boy hit the corners first
cuz the corners you can't there we go
can't forget they still walk through the
corners bitching I don't know but I know
that if I don't get the corner blocks
now I can't build them while we're
inside I'm gonna go outside to get them
ok all right
um good news oops good news um when I
dug in the dirt I got fertile dirt so
what I need to do is I just need to go
get more dirt and then I can plant this
corn and everything will be hunky-dory
it'll be great
trust me trust me I really hope there's
nothing that like flies and attacks you
that's Blatz obscure used to be like way
back when there used to be I don't know
if they took that out or not ok I
planted corn good good ID I hope it'll
do good I hope nothing stops it mm-hmm
they're really used to be things that
fly I don't I don't like that yeah like
a long time ago I don't like that
how many wood blocks do you have right
now these will be the lab that's the
last one I'll start hammering the ones
you placed I'll do it I can with what
I've got left I've got a sniper rifle
barrel and an SMG stock but
no actual things I've got shotgun parts
but yeah we need like we need a we need
like a storage box holy on it you can do
different ok good I'm going to put cloth
in there this baseball cap barrel thing
cotton fertile dirt bull casing the
spare iron brass nitrate powder led
military fiber pine seed uh this murky
water until we know a cat launcher stock
leather duster coffee beans a lot of
stuff okay a lot of stuff see that yeah
um the only thing that we need though is
we need a pot how do we make a goddamn
pot uh
there's no pot in this recipe there's
nothing maybe this is something you find
it might be we might have to go into a
pot keep searching around till we find
one okay whoa boy and it's nighttime
okay well I'll crouch down and we'll
just never speak of anything ever again
sounds sounds like the right way to go
about it yeah it's so dark Wade yeah it
is what do we do wait don't do that
that's a terrible idea why do you have
rolled-up newspaper here my armored
detective wrap newspaper of yours or
text me a newspaper on your legs
Wade you look like the craziest old man
in the waist apparently if you just
press our it'll take all and close it I
got it I got a deer yay
how do I I found a lid I found a pipe I
found a lead or lead rod or an iron rod
whatever you know whatever I want the
iron pipe yeah iron pipe that was it all
the things that I said that we're wrong
yeah that yeah thing okay so whatever
you kill it animal you're gonna use your
like hatchet or something to gather it I
guess well that makes sense that's like
from rust you got a whump it really hard
to animal fat three raw meat for hide
come on rabbit I'm gonna kill this
rabbit
okay how far am i from home oh I still
don't have a weight I need you to put a
bedroll down so I can see where our home
is
yes kill the rabbit killed wabbit kill
the wabbit
Oh can you fill empty jars up it in the
rain let me cool
um I I've got tons of jars of murky
water but are you talking like for fresh
water
yeah well that I don't know oh boy I'm
overheating I'm good
oh really yeah a blood bag a blood bag
that's one of the nurses
I keep chilling the nurses in the hopes
that they'll give us like antibiotics
and medicine and stuff yeah that's good
call yeah this airdrop must have dropped
right in the middle of the ocean because
I'm not loading up anything beyond water
like Fr around as I go I don't know
there was an ocean huh it's big it's
just a link I imagine but even so guy I
haven't found a pot damn it this is not
going well brother it's not going dude I
struck out dude I struck out hard I got
a lot of stuff I got some meat I got
some animal hide but no pot to cook it
in I can't believe that you'd have to
cry yet after school mmm what the
Thunderer oh I read of arrows the bad
time it's the guy that killed me last
time I'm coming I'm coming back
come on seriously where was that other
there was another oh no it's far away ah
my club broke too at a bad time
whew almost ran into a Zombo so I got to
get back and I got to put this meat in a
locker before four zombies get a real
sniff of it
wait I'm bleeding out no how are you
bleeding out I don't know god damn it
Wade no how many times have you died now
to count the other times seven yeah
that's what I thought too
oh god I got a spot in the desert
Goonies there's something that was like
jeez it was something there was a crawly
dude in our house
Oh probably cuz we didn't build a floor
they can probably spawn in there that's
scary oh that's no good okay I'm putting
the meat in their animal hide uh
skullcap where was my better oh you
entered I have a human turd why do I
have a human turd I don't know my bag is
just northeast of the camp I wonder how
long it'll stay there
oh jeez God now you hear it see why that
is intense yes it is holy [ __ ] alright
or if you eat an egg feed an egg raw you
get food poisoning what does that do
lower your health I don't know it just
says food poisoning 100% great whatever
it is it can't be good alright times eh
just hang out here for the night I'll
try to go back for my body tomorrow yeah
there's nothing boy I've got you need
food do you have food I have sham
sandwiches
yeah those will give food poisoning
you're under on your chest there why do
it why don't why do I want to eat those
cuz they're all we've got
wait was my chest the left one yeah a
whoops I'd dump things in the right one
okay I'm a fool I'm eating it num num
num num food poisoning yes yes yes what
time is it officially night 20 like 21 I
don't have time to make it to my body
and back then do I
okay so food poisoning apparently just
effects stamina really badly so I guess
you could eat it at night and you
generally still be okay oh yeah food
poisoning it's only lasting ten seconds
okay good oh yeah so I'm gonna put eggs
in my chest and you can click on the
eggs we need like something to cook them
in yeah I looked you can't cook without
like putting in a recipe you need water
to make boiled eggs so that would be the
cooked version because we make like a
water catcher at rain so much
ooh no wait I can make bacon and eggs oh
I can make bacon and eggs cuz if I take
this raw meat you don't need like a
skillet or a Potter pan or no you do
okay you do goddamnit you do you need
like grill oh [ __ ] you need so much
stuff bellows we need a bellows what did
you say you need to make that animal
hide like 20 of them a lot of them okay
it's made to kill a bunch of oh it's
snowing whoo whoo whoa hello snow on the
ground that's weird I didn't know that
was a thing in this biome apparently it
is now
hooray it's a Christmas miracle I'm so
glad we have a floor and a roof to keep
us warm yeah okay but if you need if you
need food real bad there's raw meat and
there's murky water I wonder what
dysentery does for you relation because
there's tons of murky water in your
chest oh I'll be careful making noise
there's a horde coming by
I'm undetected a sense to oh [ __ ] what
does that mean undetected okay it's fine
sensed undetected what does that mean
okay I'm drinking uh water
murky water well the snow came and went
real quick well there we go then it
keeps fluttering in between sensed a
nonesense that's very disconcerting
maybe I need to turn off the fire turn
off
okay none detected all right we're good
all right let's go I apparently just
pooped again okay I'm not pooped yet I
don't think I'm pooping so much probably
because I have dysentery dysentery lasts
for 40 minutes good go that's not good
is that from the murky water yeah and I
think it just affects your stamina
recovery because it's a little slower
and I might be losing tiny bit of Health
huh but it's better than being me with
only 76 of everything yeah oh we're
gonna need a second iron pipe o4y
to make the bellows ah damn it
I've got weight I've got to I've got
short iron pipes I'm gonna put them in
yours
boink a word iron pipe for that and the
bellows where was the bellows yeah yeah
too short iron pipes cool it's in your
storage awesome so we used to get a
bunch of animal hide and lumps of clay
lumps of clay okay we'll figure that out
in the next episode yeah let us know
what you think of the series if you want
to see more let us know we're surviving
pretty good in the new version of seven
days to die but it's really difficult
this is this hard yeah it is no joke I
told you it's a lot harder yeah anyway
thank you guys so much check out weights
down on the description below and thanks
again and as always we'll see you in the
next video
do you know how to get us